all right this morning Russia is taking
steps to officially Annex four Eastern
provinces of Ukraine Russia says people
there voted to leave but Ukraine's
president and his allies call the
referendums a sham Russian President
Vladimir Putin is putting more pressure
on Ukraine with a new series of attacks
Charlie dagada is in Ukraine where
civilians died in a missile strike
Charlie good morning
good morning on the day that President
Putin finalizes that land grab there has
been a horrific missile attack not far
from here on a humanitarian Convoy in
zapparesia dozens are fear dead now
there'll be an elaborate signing session
at the Kremlin followed by what we're
told is a major speech in a rally held
at Red Square in Moscow it is a dramatic
escalation and here's why to Putin's
mind those territories are now Russian
soil which he has vowed to defend by any
means necessary he's threatened to use
nuclear weapons and he says he's not
bluffing few here including president
zielinski think that he is bluffing that
might mean a small tactical nuclear
weapon used somewhere on the battlefield
is a terrifying demonstration of power
yet in the past two days Russia has
already stepped up missile attacks away
from those Russian occupied regions
bodies of victims scattered on the
ground in zapparesia they were headed to
russian-held territories to help loved
one ones Escape here in dinubro itself
we've had missile attacks overnight huge
explosions hitting civilian areas that
is the second night in a row this city
and others have been targeted Tony
dagato for us in Ukrainian Charlie thank
you very much